richard branson is one of the most
fun-loving and adventurous billionaires
in the world
with an estimated net worth of 4 billion
he was born in england into a family who
valued independence and adventure
his mother worked as an airline
attendant and his father was a lawyer
as a child richard was a budding
entrepreneur albeit a less successful
one than he is now
he once tried his hand planting 400
seeds which he would then sell as
christmas trees for a pretty profit
unfortunately
rabbits ate pretty much all of them and
ruined the plan
but he still found a way to recoup some
of his investment we won't get into the
details but let's just say those rabbits
were taken to a secondary location
he then tried his hand in breeding
parakeets vastly overestimating local
demand
at the age of 16 he left school to start
his first business
student magazine which covered a wide
range of youth culture
music and news it featured interviews
with british celebrities
like mick jagger and john lennon
expanding into an even more successful
record shop recording studio
and then record label virgin music the
first artist they signed was mike
oldfield
and his album subsequently hit the top
of the charts
virgin records was signing artists left
and right but this serial entrepreneur
needed something else
and kept busy creating new companies in
all kinds of industries
there was virgin atlantic virgin vodka
virgin mega store virgin cola virgin
mobile
virgin rail virgin galactic virgin
hotels
and virgin voyages let's just say virgin
made him a nice profit
and he debuted on the forbes
billionaires list in 1992.
he's built a lavish life for himself and
his family and keeps quite busy
launching new ventures
he currently resides on necker island in
the british virgin islands
which ironically he did not name